Computers might not be able to mimic human
intelligence, but what about a memcomputer?
Hey guys!
Amy with you on DNews today talking super
intelligent computers!
Well, maybe…
In 1950, computer scientist Alan Turing proposed
the now-famous Turing Test that challenges
anyone to build a computer that can think
like a human, success coming when a human
conversing with that computer thinks he or
she is really talking to another person.
So far, no computer has been able to pass
the Turing Test, but a new kind of computer
might be getting closer.
Universal memcomputing machines or Memcomputers,
developed by Massimiliano Di Ventra, a theoretical
physicist at the University of California,
San Diego.
They are a class of brain-inspired computers
based on human memory systems, essentially
mimicking the human brain.
It comes down to the microchip.
In a conventional microchip, the processor
executes computations and the memory stores
data.
Both are separate components necessitating
a constant relay between processor and memory,
something that consumes enough time and energy
to limit the performance of standard computers.
Memcomputers avoid this pitfall.
Physicists building these new machines are
using memprocessors at the computer’s core,
smaller units that can both process and store
data, removing this relay between the two
halves of a conventional microchip.
It’s a setup that mimics the way neurons
work in the brain.
In the brain, each neuron processes and stores
information.
So in a computer, these memprocessors save
energy, time, and ultimately improve the computer’s
performance.
Memprocessors can work together collectively
and simultaneously to attack a complex problem
from all sides, finding all possible solutions
at once to settle on the best one rather than
trying each one in turn, which is what a human
would do.
And here’s a really interesting aspect of
this story: working out the details of memcomputing
could help scientists better understand how
the brain works.
For now memcomputers are in the proof-of-concept
stage, and the way the system encodes data
makes it vulnerable to fluctuations that can
introduce errors, so this will have to be
addressed before a large-scale version can
go to work.
Still, this might be the computer that could
one day perform notoriously complex tasks
like breaking codes.
But there are other breakthrough technologies
that are changing the world and making amazing
experiences possible.
Intel drives innovation with products like
processors, wearables and IOT devices, and
within data centers.
In the PC and beyond.
Having Intel inside makes for better experiences
outside.
So what do you guys think of the prospect
of a computer that mimics the human brain?
Cool?
Or super creepy?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.